war comes suddenly
and it comes from the sky
a loud blast and everything that was
once the comfort of home
now gone
for the elderly limited in movement
many can't make it down to the
underground shelter of this nine-story
building
rescue workers pick up parts of what
used to be ordinary lives in kiev
it's hard to comprehend what is
happening here
a few hours later another strike in the
capital
this war is now into its third week
and this the view from the other side in
russian-backed separatists controlled
don yet city in the east
a large ukrainian bomb landed here on
monday and there have been casualties
here too
military analysts may be assessing that
russia's advance is slow but it is
deadly
humanitarian corridors have been agreed
upon for monday and more aid convoys are
planned
we will again try to unblock the
movement of the humanitarian convoy from
berdyansk to marriott
the port city of marrapal remains under
a devastating siege
attempts to move civilians out has
failed day after day
people may remember this heavily
pregnant mother being rescued following
a russian strike on a maternity hospital
last week
news now emerging that she and her baby
have died
on the day when the maternity hospital
was hit three women were brought here
one was in critical condition with a
crushed pelvis and a detached hip
while we were resuscitating her
and
carried out a cesarean section and took
out her lifeless child
more than 30 minutes of resuscitation
didn't produce any results then more
than 30 minutes of resuscitation of the
mother didn't produce results both died
but new life is also bringing joy here
despite being born into an uncertain
future
these are terrifying days
but there is defiance here and the
uncompromising will to survive
the war is never far away
the mental toll unbearable in a city
under bombardment nowhere feels safe
talks between both sides are expected on
monday
russia says ukraine needs to compromise
for the war to end but for now the army
the president and countless civilians
across the country who have taken up
arms to defend their nation and their
future
refuse to do so
stephanie decker al-jazeera
iman khan has more from outside the
residential building sheldon kiev
it was just after five in the morning
when an artillery shell hit the entrance
of that building we think it's an
artillery shell
now that's the entrance of a residential
building here in the north of kiev
and just take a look at the damage you
can still actually smell the burning now
rescue efforts are still continuing you
can see
the fire engine there with the ladder
going up
they're still coming through the
building street if there are any more
bodies inside we are hearing that at
least one person has been killed have
been a number of injuries as well
this is a residential building
and that was the entrance to that
building making like making the ability
for people to get out
almost impossible i mean just take a
look it's an incredible amount of damage
all the way through and on the other
side of this building as well now
shelling has taken place uh in areas
near here in european and in butcher but
this
is
inside
kiev this is north
keefe
well joining us from kiev is it's mayor
of italian kalitschko thank you very
much indeed sir for being with us we've
just been showing pictures of some of
the damage from the attacks in kiev this
morning i understand that you've been to
at least two of the sites of the attacks
how do you feel when you see what the
damage has been done
how i feel
i feel so bad
as fuel uh every ukrainian citizens
because nobody feel him safety right now
in ukraine first point
second point
the russian propaganda
zoned all russians and explain
this war
they target just
military forces
and they explain about
freedom and some mission what have
russian soldiers
to bring the peace to working against
nationalist fascist
radicals is everything it's everything
is liar
today we have a pictures if civil
building
with where live peaceful people was
destroyed
people died many injured
two two wrecked attack to kiev it's not
just first one
we have a lot of
experience in the past
couple of weeks
what do it what did
russian aggresses
and yes of course the
target to bring the the goal to bring
the
panic to the city
after these pictures
we more and more sure
we never give up
we will be fight
russians killed our children
destroyed our building
destroyed our city
we're ready to fight
ready to fight and defend our city
no never ever
russians to come to our city i promised
that as mayor of keith and i told the
people the citizens told everyone
exactly the same
right now
many people
a lot all
population uh
everyone every citizens of kiev
who never have idea to take the weapons
in the hand
right now with peaceful profession as
doctors
actors music
musicians and
any profession take the weapons and
ready to defend our future we never go
to the knee we defend our children we
defend our houses we defend our city we
defend our future
we've been reporting a lot on the
foreign weapons that have been
apparently moving into ukraine do you
believe that the people of kiev are able
to defend their city
we very appreciate for our partners for
country
who
support ukraine because we defend not
just ukraine
we defend right now the principles we
defend right now the same values
and it's very important to help ukraine
we very appreciate for humanitarian
health
for medical
delivering the medical uh
staff medical
care to the
medication to to our hometown we were
appreciated
to for
to become
defensive weapon defensive because we
defend our country
and
it's very important right now to support
ukraine because
this world
can touch anyone not just in europe
around the world because this war
against normal human principles
we have seen mayors of other cities in
ukraine being replaced
how worried are you about your own
safety
right now every ukraine
ukrainian feel unsafety with war
is everyone
a risk to die
but
the
aggressors
want to
bring panic to our city
with this attack
to civilian buildings
the the pictures what we see when kill
our children and our women
they give to us the power
we're ready to fight
we never ever give up
and we never give
uh our city
kiev
was ukrainian
city this was ukrainian capital
in will be in the future always
ukrainian because we
ready to fight and defend our city
by the way
thank you very much for for the help
it's very important for us
there we've reported on the number of
civilians who have already been
evacuated from cities like kiev can you
give us some idea of your plans to
evacuate remaining civilians should the
city be attacked directly by russia
already
thousand hundred thousands of
citizens already moved
almost is children and women
men's begged to come back to kiev and
ready to defend the city
finally sir
we understand of course that nato and
its allies are refusing to enforce a
no-fly zone over cities like kiev and
other parts of ukraine
can the people of kyiv and ukrainians
defend their country if they do not have
a no-fly zone
if natto can do it can't close air
and
no fly zone status give to ukraine
please
give to us
the modern weapons give to us the
stingers and we by itself
close the air above our heads
vitalik klitschko mayor of kiev we
appreciate your time sir thank you very
much indeed for being with us on al
jazeera
thank you
we have your correspondence in ukraine
across developments shortly we'll cross
the asset bank in nepal with more on the
humanitarian corridors stephanie
mentioned in her report first we're
going to bring in jonah hall in libby
for an update on the talks that have
been going on is there any further news
out of the
negotiations that have been happening
uh we're not getting any sort of running
commentary or updates out of those talks
they are ongoing they're happening in
the in a video conferencing format this
time the fourth time that these two
negotiating sides have met at the level
of sort of minister deputy minister and
parliamentarians uh
of course not the foreign ministers as
met in antalya turkey last
week and certainly not the president so
you know these are not ultimate decision
makers we are talking probably about
discussions over humanitarian corridors
perhaps safe zones
the deliveries of humanitarian aid
and so on certainly not
final status
measures and remember that up to now
there's been very little in the way of
breakthroughs and even the agreements
that have been reached over humanitarian
corridors have not held but there have
been some cautious signs of optimism
in comments being made by both sides
michael podeliak
an adviser to president zielinski saying
the talks
are beginning to go more constructively
russia perhaps being less ultimatum
driven in its approach he believes there
may be results in a few days
and one of the
russian negotiators leonid zlutsky
telling russian media significant
progress has been made in recent days
they're now having daily contacts by the
way on some level uh possible
draft agreements could be reached very
soon again not final peace agreements
probably more on the humanitarian level
in terms of the bigger picture when does
that begin to change well look briefly
at the battlefield now uh western
intelligence
agrees with the general staff of the
ukrainian military that very little
progress is being made by russia on the
ground
these battles around kiev yes absolutely
huge damage being caused massive
civilian
toll being caused it is
forcing a showing force reach in terms
of long-range missile fire all the way
to the west of the country but little
verifiable gains kiev still stands
kharkiv in the east still stands mario
paul improbably in the south still
stands so russia doesn't have a solid
corridor land corridor that it needs
between crimea and the east no
verifiable moves towards odessa for
instance until these concrete gains
materialize on the battlefield it's very
hard to see
russia vladimir putin meeting mr
zielenski as mr zielinski wants and
actually talking peace jonah hall and
levi jonah thank you very much indeed
okay for more on ukraine's plans to
evacuate people to safety let's speak to
al jazeera's assad who's in
in eastern ukraine jonah was just
telling us there that part of the
negotiations will be the establishing of
more humanitarian corridors what do we
know about the situation so far
well ukraine has announced the
establishment of 10 humanitarian
corridors now they're talking about the
kiev region uh where they want to
get people out that want to leave
evacuate people and also get
humanitarian aid in some of those areas
are controlled uh by russian forces but
also uh in eastern ukraine where uh
areas are controlled by separatists and
russian forces but there's still pockets
of ukrainian controlling their ukrainian
resistance but trying to get medical and
food aid in there but also evacuate
those that want to leave but also
they're really concerned about mario
paul to the south of the country that
important port city that has been
besieged
and there have been several attempts to
try and create a humanitarian corridor
to try to get aid in now in theory
talking about human humanitarian
corridors works but in reality on the
ground at least in mario paul it hasn't
for the last week and a half there's
been several attempts to try and get aid
in there was 10 food trucks there were
20 buses per time to try to evacuate
people and they were turned around and
there was allegations against the
russians saying that they had targeted
those now the russians say that they
don't target
civilians we understand yesterday aid
convoy got within two hours of mario
paul but was turned around and today
there's another attempt underway to try
and get aid in now from the authorities
in mariopol we've heard today that
they've said
private vehicles have left uh carrying
around
around one o'clock local time sorry
for the uh city of berdyansk which is
controlled by the russians also local
authorities there say that the death
toll now is 2 500 residents that's over
that's increased by over 300 since
yesterday but also from the
international committee of the red cross
now they say that the situation in
mariopol is dire that people are
traumatized that they are terrified and
there's nowhere for them to go there's
food and water shortages and people are
risking their lives to go out and try
and get some food and they're sheltering
in unheated basements and the
temperatures are well below zero so
there is a considerable concern around
the humanitarian situation in mariopol
and uh we'll find out whether uh the
country or both sides can establish
humanitarian corridors to get aid to
maripo
when jonah was talking to us about in
his roundup of the the fighting that was
going on in ukraine he said that russia
still hasn't got a solid corridor as he
called it uh from the east talk to us
about the fighting that's going on in
donetsk in the eastern part of ukraine
so yes we've heard that uh
in donetsk there was a missile strike
with their blaming on the ukrainian
forces that killed 20 people and injured
eight we can't verify that we can't
because we don't have access to those
areas that are controlled by russian
troops and separatists but even to the
north of
which is the second largest city in
ukraine the russians still haven't been
able to take that they've hit that with
shells with air strikes and missiles and
they tried entering the city but the
ukrainians did
push them back they held out and it
still isn't under
russian control but there are places
around the east where the russians seem
to be making small progress but it's not
it's very slow it's not a major because
the ukrainians are managing to resist
but we've also heard uh the ashellas hit
the city of kramertusk and killed a
residential building and killed two
people so they're still
there's still fighting taking place but
again as you said the russians don't
seem to have had many major gains
assad being talking to us from nipro i
said thank you very much indeed
when the kremlin insists it's got enough
resources for what it calls its military
campaign in ukraine russia also says
it's being carefully planned to avoid
civilian casualties but that the u.s and
the eu are trying to provoke it into
attacking major population centers
joining us now from moscow there have
been a series of comments that have been
coming out from the kremlin um what have
they been saying
well the kremlin spokesperson dmitry
paskov during his daily briefing
said that according to the russian
defense ministry they were instructed at
the beginning of the so-called special
military operation in ukraine not to
go into the large heavily populated
cities and that is at the request of
course of the russian president vladimir
putin and he said that this kind of
rhetoric and these accusations coming
from western leaders uh is provocative
because they are trying to force russia
into
larger cities where there will be
certainly civilian casualties and to
blame russia for those casualties and
that is something that of course he says
the russian president has asked the
defense ministry to avoid at all costs
it was also noteworthy that he said that
for the first time we're hearing this of
what is the possible plan for these
russian forces in ukraine according to
dmitry peskov he said that the russian
military does not rule out the
possibility of taking under full control
of large populated areas in ukraine to
ensure maximum safety for the civilian
population hinting at possibly
the russian troops are going to be
staying in certain areas of ukraine once
they have captured certain cities and
carried out what they're calling their
special military operation the
spokesperson for the kremlin also said
that their operation is going according
to plan and they will finish it in the
amount of time that it's been allotted
he didn't specify how long
is still left of that and he also said
to the rumors that russia has asked
china for military aid he said that is
absolutely not true that russia is fully
capable of carrying out this operation
with all the military hardware that they
have already
and in the meantime there is of course
more diplomacy this time the foreign
ministers of qatar and russia have been
taught in talks as well
yes the qatari foreign minister arrived
in moscow on sunday muhammad bin abdul
rahman al-thani met with the russian
foreign minister sergey lavrov for about
an hour and a half earlier on monday and
then they made a brief statement
following their meeting
clearly they had a lot to discuss of
course the qatari foreign minister said
that qatar was very much
looking for
any possibility to assist in getting
some kind of very peaceful resolution to
the crisis in ukraine and that the
qataris will not spare any expense to
bring about peace on that front and he
also said that they were very concerned
about the escalation and violence and
that he was very much looking forward to
trying to provide as much assistance to
the russians as possible
and the russian foreign minister sergey
lavrov also seemingly very happy to see
his qatari counterpart here in moscow he
said that they appreciate the help and
assistance and support of the qatari
officials and that their cooperation
will continue they also discuss the
future of that nuclear deal that has
been stalled in vienna as a result of a
certain number of demands made by
russians about the sanctions that
they're now under by the u.s government
of course all of this will be further
discussed at later discussions because
the two foreign ministers said that the
dialogue between the two countries will
continue
dorsa dr jabari in moscow thank you very
much indeed
well the u.s and china have held
high-level talks in rome the white house
sees the meeting as critically important
for the war in ukraine this after the
u.s accused russia of seeking military
aid from china well adam rainey is
joining us live from rome what's at
stake for china adam coming out of these
talks
well to put it blatantly business as
usual what is at stake according to the
national security advisers the united
states jake sullivan
is business trade major uh important
issues for china the eu is china's
largest trading partner china is the
largest supplier of goods to the united
states and what jake sullivan has been
saying in the last 48 hours is that a
lot of that trade is at risk if china
delivers any material or military or
financial support to russia during this
war now this is a very sensitive issue
to china because it's trying to thread
an increasingly small needle here it's
been saying that it it
supports
ukraine sovereignty independence but
going into this war when uh xi jinping
met vladimir putin in china he said that
they had a rock-solid uh partnership
that there was nothing that could put it
at risk now a few weeks into this war
that doesn't necessarily still seem to
be the case because china is having to
waste some decisions that perhaps did
not want to make and the us is clearly
trying to make those decisions tougher
for china
if any sanctions were to be put in place
that could put at risk billions of
dollars of trade in the next weeks and
months this is also coming at a time
that china is facing its largest
outbreak of kovid since the early days
of the pandemic many factories are being
closed down or reduced in some of the
industrial heartland of china so that's
that's the main thing at stake business
but what what is going to be tricky for
china is it's trying to say that of
course this is not taking place that
russia hasn't asked them for any help
they've been characterizing this as fake
news without outrightly rejecting these
claims so i think the next 24 hours we
might see statements from both sides
coming out of these meetings it's been
very tight-lipped here in rome but the
fact that these talks are taking place
in italy is another important factor to
take into consideration italy is one of
the main uh countries in the european
union although it has large ties with
russia it has given its full support to
these incredible unprecedented sanctions
that have been put in place against
russia since the beginning of this war
and china is not blind to that fact they
know this is a different world than it
was a few weeks ago before the war and
they're going to be weighing all of
these
these threats basically coming from the
united states that although it's just
right now the national security adviser
of the us who's been holding these talks
that the fact that they're taking place
in europe implies
that europe might also be willing to put
in place some uh some punitive measures
that might make doing business with
china a little trickier for them to come
that's adam rainey talking to us from
rome adam thank you very much indeed
well laurence cobb is a former assistant
secretary of defense and also a senior
fellow at the center for american
progress he's joining us live from
washington dc good to have you with us
sir on al jazeera what kind of pressure
and arguments do you think that jake
sullivan is going to be using in these
meetings with china
well i think he can say that if they
should provide military assistance to
russia
basically that
they're going to be sanctioned just like
russia has and cut off trade with the
european union as well as with the
united states and the european union is
china's largest trading partner a lot of
the things that china needs for its
economic well-being they get from the
from the united states so i think jake
is going to try and tell the china you
have two choices you can
be the peacemaker or you can create
havoc for your country
it is a slightly difficult situation one
would imagine the us finds itself and to
us china not to support its ally russia
either economically or militarily when
of course the us and nato and its nato
allies are doing precisely that uh for
ukraine it's it's a fine line isn't it
well there's no doubt about it now the
meeting that they had between the heads
of china and russia during the olympics
basically china said they agreed with
russia that ukraine should not become
part of nato they did not sanction uh
the the invasion and it was very
interesting when the u.n came up with a
resolution condemning
russia china didn't vote no they abstain
which i think was a signal they're
trying to have it both ways they don't
want to antagonize russia because they
see that as a counterweight to the
united united states but on the other
hand they did not want to support it
because the international order that
they depend upon for their economic
well-being is uh in jeopardy when one
country can just invade another
country's no apparent reason
i want to ask you about this line that
the u.s uh was putting out that it
accused russia of seeking military aid
from china given your experience sir um
in defense matters is that a surprise to
you that russia would need to do
something like that
well i think what happened is president
putin underestimated how difficult and
prolonged this war was going to be so he
was not prepared he thought by massing
175 or 200 000 troops
ukraine would cave and he'd march in
like he did in 2014 but he's
found out that he's had to expend an
awful lot of
ammunition and supplies like that that
he may not have stockpiled ahead of this
and so
it's not surprising that russia needs it
but again who else would they get it
from china is the only uh country that
would have that type of ammunition and
the only one that has uh supported
russia
now i believe you met vladimir putin
back in 1990 given your impression of
him then the way what was there anything
in his personality and anything that you
saw that give you any indication that me
he might be where he is now with this
invasion of ukraine
no i mean he was a you know at that time
he was a uh you know kgb officer who was
you know leaving the kgb as the cold war
ended and he was the deputy mayor of
leningrad so he was a very very orderly
person and a very good administrator and
he was put in to take russia over when
yeltsin had created chaos they wanted
somebody to kind of restore order and
get russia back uh cubing his economic
development nobody envisioned him coming
in and trying to restore the glory days
of uh of the of the soviet uh uh empire
and we saw this real early to what he
did in chechnya uh when the in the
beginning russia had not done well
fighting chechnya he came in and just
was brutal what he did and that gave an
indication of who he really was which we
had never known before because he was a
relatively minor kgb
officer
as always we appreciate your expertise
in this lawrence corp thank you very
much indeed for joining us
thank you for having me